I think it's like very important to pick
things you're passionate about and
curious about but then ultimately how
successful you are as an entrepreneur is
in your ability to make high quality
decisions this episode is very exciting
at least for me because this is a
conversation between me and Daniel eek
who is the co-founder and CEO of spotify
and we're here because of an exciting
new announcement that they've just
unveiled at an event last night and that
is all about audiobooks so basically
audiobooks are now coming to Spotify in
this conversation me and my new pal
Daniel talk about a bunch of interesting
things firstly we talk about what this
audiobooks feature means for the
industry at large and how it's going to
affect Publishers and authors and of
course readers and listeners secondly we
talk about Daniel's approach to building
businesses and Daniel talks about the
Frameworks that entrepreneurs can use to
think about how they add value and we
talk about the balance between thinking
and action and Daniel share some
interesting and somewhat
counterintuitive thoughts on what most
entrepreneurs do wrong I'm interested in
solving like many other entrepreneurs
big problems for people I'm not so
interested in creating you know a
gimmicky thing that people may find some
amusement in but next we move on to
something else I would look for a
problem where it Pace off to be faster
and we talk about time management we
talk about focus and we talk about work
life balance as it relates to the fact
that Daniel's obviously running this
huge company and a couple of other
companies as well and is also balancing
his life as a father and a husband I do
what I love to do so I have a lot of fun
while doing it I don't live to work but
I really enjoy what I do too so it
doesn't feel like a huge drag you shoot
for the stars and you land on the moon
you might just as well tackle something
that's really hard because if you tackle
something that's really hard it's more
likely that you create a lot of value
than if you tackle something that's
simple Daniel welcome to the podcast
thank you very much thank you so much
for having us here this is an exciting
time for you guys yeah well thank you so
much for coming here to New York uh I
feel honored yeah mate first time in New
York like it was it was incredible that
you guys invited us out here um so you
guys have recently announced the
audiobook thing for people who might not
have heard of what this is can you can
you give us a rundown of what does this
mean for listeners yeah sure um so so
the the basics of what we announced is
starting yesterday um um audiobooks uh
well actually all Spotify Premium users
in UK and Australia now have audiobooks
as part of their package so they get 15
hours uh worth of listening as part of
their uh subscription from a library of
more than 150,000 titles to choose from
so you'll have an amazing set of of of
uh titles that you'll be able to listen
to as part of your Spotify Premium
subscription and then in addition to
that you can obviously top up for more
hours if you like it or purchase books
on an all card basis just like you could
before yeah I think it's going to be
it's going to be incredible like I've
I've just got access to it on my Spotify
app because obviously it's UK based yeah
and just the the speed at which I can
now sample audiobooks great cuz I don't
need to worry about like a credit system
where it's like number of things per
month and and all that kind of stuff
yeah exactly right and and um I I think
what's going to happen is um like you
said people are going to now take the
bet on authors that they might have not
otherwise done just because they're
curious and interested uh and a big
problem with the previous credit model
was you kind of had one shot and so
you're more likely to take the things
you know you like um and and do that
rather than bet on anything new so the
thing that probably excites me the most
is just going to be seeing how
consumption is going to be different and
what kind of authors might do well in
this world
uh and inversely also there may be some
authors that don't do as well uh as they
normally would so breaking into
audiobooks like it's a pretty old school
system Legacy providers very in like
publishing the publishing industry in
general is quite like entrenched with
like the big five
Publishers how did you guys go about
kind of becoming an entrance to this
market and I guess becoming the first
viable competitor to audible yeah well I
I I think um our DNA is a little bit
different in that um we started out
respecting copyright and working with
Partners uh there's a lot of tech
companies that tend to take the approach
build a platform and then whatever comes
comes and then eventually you get to
certain size where you kind of need to
codify it and start adapting to the
existing Industries we kind of take this
approach uh the inverse approach where
we don't mind going into something where
you may even have a few big players you
work within the system to try to change
it so um you know a lot of people talk
about disruption I I dislike the word
because it typically kind of implies
that you're wrecking a havoc on what's
already there and just like we did in
music we actually like working with the
ecosystem try to see if there's a
win-win outcome where creators win and
consumers win at the same time so I
think we took the same mindset that we
had in music um beforehand and applied
it to audiobooks and said we understand
your problems and we spent the better
part of two years just trying to
understand what their issues were
fundamentally before we introduced the
model and the big realization was like
just like in music uh there was one
dominating player uh that was there
before and it was kind of stagnant with
Innovation and just like in music uh it
was actually quite small number of
people that were in this legal
environment from where we thought uh the
world should look like uh if I look at
Germany as a great example you know in
Germany um the book Market is about half
audiobooks and half uh physical books
and the same has now happened in Sweden
um so if you think about that um you
know I think the number right now is
about 5% in the US and probably I would
guess I I don't know the numbers but
probably similar 5 10% in the UK so that
means that audiobooks is massively under
penetrated uh and we need to bring
innovation in order to do so so by
making this part of all Spotify members
we bring two things to Bear one is we
bring scale straight away which makes
this exciting for Publishers and two you
uh are introducing a whole new
generation that perhaps may not have
purchased a separate audiobook
subscription but now that this is part
of their existing uh audio service
already they get both better consumption
experience and are more likely to try
new things as well sick yeah I I can't I
can't wait to try this out and just
sample tons and tons of a books um a
general question about you know when it
comes to business
entrepreneurship obviously Spotify has
been quite you know to use that word
disruptive uh when it comes to for
example the music industry but there are
a lot of businesses that you know if if
someone had the idea of you know even
something like stripe where it's like
hey let's do payments or something like
that and you and then they think there
that's going to involve a lot of deal
making a lot of talking to people a lot
of trying to convince existing providers
that this is a good idea compared to
doing something that doesn't require any
of that yeah you know music audiobooks
payments these are all like hard
problems because you're having to do a
lot Beyond just whip up a few bits of
code which is I guess how a lot of
people think of software startup these
days if you were advising new
entrepreneurs who are looking at
opportunities that seem hard versus
opportunities that seem less hard yeah
how how would you go about kind of
tackling that well so so I think that
there's two things that are important to
State whether you only have to do um a
little bit of code or whether you have
to do a lot of work the first thing is
to try to understand how do you create
value and for whom um and so in a lot of
cases what I noticed is that uh if it is
very easy to go about something um it is
easy to try ideas that's the positive
thing so occasionally you may stumble
upon them something that becomes a great
success but I think we don't talk about
the inverse um enough which is because
it's sheap you tend to not have to think
things through and so many of these
experiments then end up getting faulty
and um you know we talking about minimum
viable project products MVPs and so on I
actually don't subscribe to the theory
at all I'm I'm kind of um opposed to
minimal viable products um instead I
think you should take the time to think
through uh what problems you're solving
and for whom and I think the experim
first experiments actually dictate
subsequent experiments as well so I I I
would just say the first thing is to try
to like really no matter who you are and
whether it's a big effort or small
effort um you're going to have to think
through the problem well and that in
itself is a big exercise no matter if if
the actual implementation then is fast
or slow and then the second thing is um
you know what when I think about all the
problems they're left um I think about
the worlds and and bits atoms and genes
right and so um we started all of us as
Internet entrepreneurs we were solving
mostly bits only problems but when you
think about the really interesting
things that are happening at the moment
they're all kind of in this interplay
between bits and atoms and in some cases
maybe bits and genes um with you know
the kerian pharmaceutical company and a
bunch of all these other companies that
doing really interesting stuff in in
biotech so I think that the most
interesting opportunities are in those
things that are kind of problematic
anyway where you have to master many
skills and then the last thing I would
just say is the the you know you shoot
for your for the stars and you land on
the moon I I tend to think that it's it
things in the end usually back to my
first point ends up being about the same
amount of work anyway so you might just
as well tackle something that's really
hard because if you tackle something
that's really hard it's more likely that
you create a lot of value then if you
tackle something that's simple so maybe
that's me post rationalizing and getting
into really difficult businesses and and
and so on but um I'm interested in
solving like many other entrepreneurs
big problems for people I'm not so
interested in creating you know a
gimmicky thing that people may find some
amusement in but next week move on to
something
else so let's say someone's listening to
this and they're a you know they'
they've got a normal job and they want
to start a business initially on the
side you know and try and try and build
it up into a thing and they might be
thinking of like okay there's this hard
problem I want to tackle but you know
Daniel's got his team of 10,000 plus
employees and he's got all the money and
all that kind of stuff what are some
what are some ways that that solo
entrepreneur can start thinking about
tackling these he problems well I mean
again if you are starting to go up
against a big
incumbent uh in whatever field you're
doing um I think the most um under
appreciated things is um is to to to
almost think about you know there is
informational advantages you can have
right there's analytical advantages you
can have and then there behavioral
advantages you can have and I like to go
after things that where you can have
behavioral advantages so I would look
for a problem that where you where where
pce off to be faster and like in a
bigger company one of the things that's
bu example is that you can't take the
same amount of risks on the regulatory
side or the legal side but very often
things that are highly disruptive for
instance tend to be things that are kind
of in that Gray Zone where it's not
super I'm not saying it's illegal but
it's not clear if it's super legal
either so you have an advantage um as a
younger company to go up against an
incumbent in there so I would just go
for things where you can have some sort
of Behavioral Advantage where it pays
off to be faster where it pays off to be
a smaller team Etc but then in addition
to that the true unique thing I really
do believe is if you're a high quality
individual even if you have a job on
your side in order to um you know pay
the rent and all the the other stuff if
if you are spending thousands of hours
thinking about a problem that is highly
unique in this world there aren't a lot
of high quality people spending
thousands of hours thinking about how to
solve a certain problem you're very
likely to come up with very unique
Solutions and that sort of touches upon
the conversation we had prior right
about um sort of you know how to think
uh about these things the minimum viable
thing I think most of the work happens
to be the same no matter if it's a hard
problem you're tackling or a simple one
which just really thinking things
through um you know thinking is uh sheep
um that's the real MVP part
here what do you mean by informational
or analytical advantages well I think of
the world like again um if you're a big
um company the the reality is let's say
Spotify is a great example we have an
audience of more than 550 million users
we're naturally going to have an
informational Advantage around
consumption behaviors relative to so a
new entrance so naturally that gives us
a lot of of opportunities uh like one
way we're using it in the case of
audiobooks is we're looking for uh is
your music taste um a possible indicator
what kind of books you may like um you
know I don't know if it is but maybe it
is uh if so then we would have um
certainly an advantage relative to
someone who's starting fresh in in
audiobooks so that would be an example
of that an analytical Advantage would be
for some reason you happen to sit on the
50 experts in the world um about this
particular issue every PhD you kind of
bought up and have them locked up in a
locker then you may have some sort of
analytical Advantage there's a much
harder to kind of like um understand but
investors typically talk about having
sort of an informational advantage or an
analytical Advantage but I think the
most underutilized and underappreciated
of them is when you can have a
behavioral Advantage you can just behave
in ways that other people can't or don't
want
to and how did that the I guess in the
early days of Spotify you guys took a
very different behavioral approach
compared to what other people were doing
what what did that look like back in the
day um well I I think um and back then
um it manifested itself in many ways and
and I guess it also depends relative to
other people but one of the behavior of
things we were we were a Silicon Valley
type company out of Stockholm Sweden um
so relative to other European companies
we were way more Silicon Valley
playbooks of of you know scaling things
moving fast technology being an enabler
for various things so against them we
did a lot of things uh very right um
against a Silicon Valley company we were
a European company and that had certain
other advantages uh for instance the
talent Market uh didn't look the same uh
in there so we could have our pick of
the talents so the best of the best of
the best because there wasn't many other
startups around when we started out uh
which was an enormous Advantage another
thing too was that our first initial
Market wasn't the US it was Sweden and I
I can tell you that if we had started in
the US as the First Market Spotify would
not be around today but because by
picking a much smaller Market that
everyone else thought was uninteresting
we were not only because we were there
on the ground we were able to see the
signals but it also didn't matter uh to
the same extent and the first couple of
iterations of what we were building
probably wouldn't have been impossible
to take in the biggest markets in the
world and get in the record labels to
buy in and say hey we're going to risk
everything and by the way this guy comes
around 23y old guy and he's telling us
to give away our music for free because
then people will want to pay for it
right of course they didn't want to do
that uh so I probably would have then
had to settled for a much worse product
and proposition whereas in
Sweden um the market was small enough
and I was able to convince them but also
promised them through guaranteeing them
revenues um for that market so for them
it was kind of win if Spotify loses we
still get another year of run rate if
Spotify wins um this might be quite
interesting so so it really wasn't as
big of a bet but if i' tell you from the
beginning if I come to you and sayy Al
give me all your content for free and by
giving it away for free we're going to
get people to pay for it but we won't
tell you how and by by the way this is
back in 2008 so now people are more
aware of it and no one's paying for
anything on the internet back then yeah
you probably would have laughed me out
of the the house but because I did that
coupled with also basically saying
here's another Year's um pay where you
you saw your existing business crumbling
from underneath you it's like okay I'll
I'll try this don't believe it works but
at least it gives me a few more months
of Runway nice um one thing that we we
touched upon is this sort of um you said
uh you know thousands of hours of
thinking thinking is the thing that can
can give you the advantage H how do you
think of you know there are there are a
lot of people that I know that we have
in our audience who are almost Paralyzed
by thinking about things they'll think
about starting a YouTube channel for
ages well they think about starting a
podcast or writing a book yeah for
absolutely ages and never take action so
how do you think about this balance
between the analysis the thinking versus
actually just doing the thing yeah and
and and you're exactly right too so what
I often tell entrepreneurs is that um
you know if you even start something
you're better than 99% um other people
right so um you know this is why I don't
like giving advice because people tend
to take you literally whereas the
reality is it's the sum of many
different things that you have to do but
you're you're exactly right I do think
you have to get started and you have to
do stuff and and it's by being half
pregnant that you kind of like the
amount of times that I wanted to quit
Spotify but I couldn't because I felt
like um I was half pregnant I had a team
they were dependent on me and I just had
to power through and it's by just pure
grits that eventually we were able to
overcome certain things so so I think
that is equally true in addition to that
but I would say um I generally think
when I meet entrepreneurs that they've
under thought um uh the space the
solution what value they're creating for
who and if they spent a little bit more
time than that they would have avoided
some other problems that then gets very
painful by learning it after hand so
it's it's a combination you have to get
started like you said and I think that's
the problem for 99% I still to be
candidate I'm I'm I'm thinking this out
loud now but I'm not sure if that is a
good thing or bad thing for for Humanity
maybe it is by default so that it is
good that there's a certain barrier for
us all to start things um in the
beginning um but you're right it's true
with exercise it's true with most thing
um with this world getting started is
the hardest part yeah I think early on
in my I guess entrepreneur career I very
much drank the Kool-Aid of like just get
started to do the thing and now that I
look back on it I think it that attitude
served me in some parts of the journey
but it hamstrung me in other parts of
the journey actually this morning we
started our first um like you know we've
got a team of 13 people so every week
we've started a thing where 9:00 a.m. on
a Wednesday morning 1 hour everyone's on
Zoom slack is off everyone has a pen and
paper and notebook and just thinks about
the area of the business and that
already for me for everyone in the team
has already led to so many insights cuz
just even just taking that one hour a
week to just think and nothing else is
so rare in a world where there's
constantly stuff to do yeah no I think
you're right like this constant
Interruption um is a real issue and
Psych logically um we're we're ill
equipped to deal with it so I think U
that's certainly True by the way the one
of my board members posted something you
might be interested in I think it was
yesterday he talked about
single-threaded Mee meetings versus
multi-threaded meetings so the basic
gist was that uh most of us tend to
think that there's kind of one type of
meeting we end up having which is kind
of we all go around the circle we talk
about things and it's one topic and so
on and so he has some interesting ideas
that absurd from especially remote
companies and two where they're able to
have um one of them he did uh he was a
YouTube uh uh before and he called it
the bullpen meeting so basically like
you bring everyone together and you slot
kind of like you do uh for one or two
hours um it just happens to be everyone
can talk about it whatever but because
it's not scheduled that leads to totally
different types of interactions so that
was his thing but he then lists a bunch
of other companies and what they're
doing in order to to have more
productive meetings so I would highly
recommend you to reading that oh nice
yeah I will check it out um one thing I
want to talk about before we talk about
Creator economy stuff you you mentioned
you know the phrase high quality
entrepreneurs and you mentioned that you
know at Spotify you're trying to I guess
like everyone has high higher the best
of the best I wonder what are the traits
you've seen that are common amongst the
highest performers the the sort of the
the best people that you work with the
people that you think oh I would love to
clone this person 100 times yeah what do
what are there like behavioral traits
the the the honestly the single um
biggest indicator uh is their ability to
learn um I don't think it's about skill
uh or knowledge because if you solving
problems you're going to end up
inevitably getting into situations where
you end up not knowing everything so yes
initially uh if you have a lot of uh
expertise about a certain domain it does
help because you can avoid running into
all sorts of problems Etc but but
certainly when you're solving problems
um and I think that's the most important
thing for any entrepreneur or executive
to try to do it's the quality of
decision- making you're going to be
forced um by meeting lots of of um
different things that you don't know
anything about or you know very little
about it and so then it's really your
ability to learn under a short period of
time and how you learn and so what I
often time try to do is I try to observe
how people learn and their innate
ability to learn and and that then comes
into curiosity how curious are they uh
what patterns do they so I'm interested
in novel ways that people accumulate
information if they find like this kind
of hidden path somewhere on this
subreddit thread that like I don't even
know how they got there that's
interesting uh if if it turns out that
they're excellent in extracting
information from other human beings that
don't normally like to share their
secret but everyone feel very
comfortable around them that's also
could be another skill there are many
ways to do so but um the Curiosity of
learning and the ability to learn over
short periods of times I think is the
the um biggest indicator of what
eventually will be a high quality
entrepreneurs so you have to do
something that you're innately curious
about uh and you're passionate about
right because otherwise you wouldn't
have pursued it um so I think that's the
fallacy one people look at people like
myself and say oh that's going to be
great so I think it's like very
important to pick things you're
passionate about and C about but then
ultimately how successful you are as an
entrepreneur um is in your ability to
make high quality decisions but how are
you supposed to make high quality
decisions about things you know nothing
about in my case learning the
intricacies of copyright law and making
decisions around there or how do you
hire a great CFO if you've never seen
one how do you hire a great CFO for a
publicly traded company that's like a
totally different challenge than the
first person who keeps your book books
around and pays the build um and the bar
keeps going up and there are new and new
and new challenges constantly and you
can't it is impossible to have
experience in all these things uh hence
your ability to learn over a short
period of time I think is the uh highest
indicator of success nice do you have a
like a executive coach or anything like
that um I do um but to be honest I I
work with various people in various
parts of my journey so I'm not one who's
had like one mentor and that person's
stuck around with me I tend to work with
people uh again uh that I find like um
has a corner of things um where I may
not have much experience um prior um and
I'm able to pick up a lot of things
because that person has that so so um I
I tend to look for um thinkers who are
in a very probably quite far field from
myself and and then I tend to work with
them for a while I don't um it might be
a year might be a two twoyear extin then
for a while I don't work with anyone and
then I find a new one U that I can learn
from and try to um you know surround
myself with people who are thinking very
differently than what I do Ching goes a
bit one of one of the things that I
think sort of music streaming platforms
have done is um expand I guess the
middle class of musicians cuz I guess
back in the day uh I mean and still to
an extent
there's a tiny amount of people making
all of the money but um you know hearing
some of the stats that your team was
sharing it sounds like you know there
are loads of more people that now make a
living through Spotify streaming than
there were in the past but at the same
time there are tens of millions of
people that can now post their music on
Spotify post their videos on YouTube
whatever the thing might be who are not
making any music at all yeah so I wonder
how do you think of how how do you think
the audiobook thing in particular will
change the way that creators or AU
write books and I guess the monetization
side of that as well yeah um I don't
know and I I mean if if you would have
asked me how the music industry would
have changed uh in some ways it changed
beyond what I would have ever uh
believed and in some ways it changed
less than what I ever believed as well
um you know the reality is that uh the
way uh the music industry still works is
quite similar to how it's worked 15 20
years ago yes the the the way how you
measure success is through streams
instead of sales today but how you anr
something how you Market uh something is
still quite similar um in many regards
and so I I I don't profess to know how
it's going to change I think uh again to
the extent that it will change my guess
would be that uh you're going to see a
bigger diversity of authors being
successful than the historical models
and it's quite simple from first
principles which means you know in in
the music world we went from if you had
to pay a dollar for every song you
essentially wanted to listen to the
barrier was quite high for you to try a
new song that you from a new artist that
you didn't know anything about um unless
you had a massive amount of disposable
income of course um and then piracy came
along and what ended up happening is
people started sampling from lots of
other places and then Spotify really was
about an easier way than piracy and then
that slowly turned the industry around
again to monetization so I think what's
going to happen now in the book industry
that mostly work on the credit system
that you talked about which is very
similar to buying a book um just flat
out um the
the you are purchasing books by authors
um you know um either know or you have a
high degree of trust so you end up going
on recommendations and other things um
like you initially said I think you're
going to sample a lot more now just
because the title seems interesting or
because one person mentioned it where it
would have taken five or six or seven
before so I think you're going to see a
wider diversity of authors and that in
turn uh May of course hopefully lead to
more authors being signed because all of
the sudden um the traditional Norms of
what constitutes what would work as a
successful author or not will probably
be changed now the second question is
the length of a book and all these
things if you'd ask me like um again
would I imagined streaming um changing
the length of a song um down to
something the answer probably would have
been yes but in reality there hasn't
been enormous amount we went from about
uh 430 to today uh
350 um something like that it's not
changed to 30 second songs it it's still
pretty much the same entity that it was
before it tends to be the longer intros
does worse but then again you have a
Taylor Swift that comes along and then
the longer intros work again I think so
much is just around novelty people want
to hear what's familiar but then yeah
what's surprising too and of course if
you're an established artist you
probably will get a few more extra
seconds before someone will judge your
work um so you can do something else
where it's the first time um you know
artists uh and author probably got to
hook you straight away because you might
not give it as many pages so I think it
will impact but I think this is the
beautiful thing right uh of having uh
millions of people and having a platform
um that authors in the end are going to
experiment with we're going to see it
and I don't know and I don't know what
consumers will like and what will
resonate I don't know what authors will
like but I think it'll be different yeah
I can't wait to see how the how the
world changes um my book is is is coming
at end of December and so we're just
thinking damn the introduction is even
more important than what it was
previously yeah um I'd love to talk um
just to end about productivity so we
were talking at the the party yesterday
you mentioned you're a bit of a a
productivity Enthusiast and I'm curious
because you know you're you know this
ridiculously highflying CEO of a massive
like publicly traded company your time
is on a massive premium so what are the
strategies that you and your team use to
help you squeeze the most out of your
time or is is that even the way that you
think about it um yeah it it it is how I
think about it because I think the most
valuable thing you can invest is your
time um and so on a personal basis I
can't say that I I always succeed in
doing it but I I do try to um make sure
that um you know again very simple
things but make sure I have um start
today in a perfect way so one one of the
great things that I try to do is I try
to um not start today by getting
interrupted by phone calls notifications
reading emails and all those things but
but just start the day with the first
half an hour an hour just um slow
reading things that aren't urgent but
are just uh thought provoc provocative I
try to do exercise in the morning
because it gives me more energy
throughout the rest of the day even if
it's just a walk um walk is actually my
preferred thing um although I do more
strength training these days because
it's easier to fit into the schedule so
I struggle like most people but I do try
to my morning ritual is incredibly
important to set my mental state in the
right thing um and it is boosting my
productivity that would be one thing the
other thing is I don't schedule as much
things as you think um so you may think
uh I'm a very busy
person and I uh I am in some ways but in
some ways I'm not most people are
surprised if if they get a glimpse of my
calendar because it's quite empty there
are weeks when I have a lot to do um
like uh this week um I'm sort of back to
back to back but most of my weeks are um
pretty empty I usually have one or two
things in during the day and the rest of
the time um is time off and I think
psychologically that messes with a lot
of people because they're like well I'm
not doing anything I'm not very
productive but I think you have to the B
the biggest learning I've had I used to
back in the day I used to model myself
on other people that were successful and
that I looked up to and that I thought
did very great things so again I'll I'll
use an example my board member
shashir he um he published a lot of his
productivity ritual and he's kind of a a
geek and on this stuff so he he um he
publishes a mockup calendar of what his
week look like um and I thought it was
brilliant because he has many smart
smart ideas on on like onetoone meetings
one to many meetings many to many
meetings and all these kind of like
variant of these things and um Regular
Cadence for this this this this this and
then occasional Cadence for this and
this so it's just a great system the
problem was um I copied it uh from him
straight off because I was like this is
brilliant and the problem um that I
ended up um running into two weeks into
it I was I was about to kill myself
because it was like the worst schedule
ever I didn't feel any energy at all uh
I did a lot of things but I wasn't very
productive and um my realization through
that process is you have to do things
you have to understand your own
psychology
uh uh and you have to understand where
you can add the most amount of Leverage
and we are all different some people get
a lot of energy from meeting people uh
some people are great
delegators um and get their done most of
their work done because they're able to
get other people to do the majority of
the work uh and they're kind of just the
spider kind of coordinating all those
things some people are more creative and
they they um they are better off when
you have two or three or four
um hours of blocked out time and they
need that in order to produce high
quality work so they don't do a lot but
they do fewer things of higher quality
and I think um you have to think about
it um as an individual like both what
your own psychology is so that you can
get the maximum out of yourself but you
also have to think about the surrounding
um so I get that you may not be able to
take four hours off even if it's your
psychology if you work a 9 to 5 job and
you have a boss who tells you to show up
for various meetings totally understand
that but to the extent that you can be
true to your psychology I think you'll
you'll you'll make um and increase
massive amounts of productivity gains
but we think we have to adhere to this
schedule so let's translate that back
now to me to the question you asked but
I felt like I had to um explain a little
bit more about more more My Philosophy
to productivity first um so in my case I
I don't have a lot of things um blocked
out not because um um not not because I
look at it as I'm the creative person or
I'm not I I would actually say I'm a
hybrid and I think most people are a
hybrid of both um but the most important
thing for me is to be able to roam free
to the highest uh and most important
area and what I find is that by
pre-booking that in advance I set up
myself for failure so that I don't have
enough time for the things that truly
end up in this kind of important and
quite urgent things um that the business
needs to to take care of and I have a
team that tends to deal with a lot of
things for me but my my biggest job and
my biggest help is actually providing
leverage for them and the way to do that
is um you know many of them run the
day-to-day and run lots of people and
Orcs And meetings and all that stuff it
is like they get a hairy problem they
don't know what to do about that problem
it may take two or three or four or five
hours or even two weeks um to sort that
out um that's where I do my best work
and that is sometimes negotiating deals
that is sometime get really in the weeds
of a product strategy thing and like
sort out uh everything from how the
button Works to whatever other things um
there may be and sometimes uh that's
almost like being a coach interviewing
everyone of the team understanding why
the team isn't working so that I can go
to that leader and suggest what we
should be doing differently but that's
because I like playing that part and um
I feel useful in that part and my
psychology is one where uh I tend to
want to have a lot of free time in order
to jump to the highest value action um
it's not so much that other leaders uh
couldn't have done it differently and
probably made it work uh very well for
them as well that's great um how do you
think about the balance between you know
you want to do a lot of things versus
the value of focusing on like one or two
or three things and I guess I'm curious
because if we just think about Spotify
you know you guys are doing great at
music then you added podcasts and now
you've added audiobooks I know that
you've started a couple of other
companies as well you've got the health
one and
like you know there's there there's one
side of people that says focus on the
single most important thing but then
there's like clearly sometimes more than
one important thing how how do you how
do you jugle that balancing out yeah
it's it's funny you mentioned that we
have most of my um senior um Executives
um here in New York at this moment and I
was just giving a talk about precisely
that um and and so one one way I like to
think about it is there's um there's a
framework called the Eisenhower Matrix
um the basic gist is it's a 2 by two
grid uh important not important urgent
not urgent and cognitively I think we
struggle with everything that's urgent
um both urgent important and Urgent not
important and um I think most people are
pretty good at procrastinate on the
things that's um not important um and uh
not urgent right like we we're able to
kind of not do those things um I think
we struggle in doing uh the important uh
the sorry the Urgent um not important
and I think we struggle with the
important and not urgent um so those are
the two quadrants to to focus more on um
and and there it it is really tricky but
I think the most uh important thing I
would I would give as advice is to if
you keep your eyesight if you don't
think in increments of weeks and months
but you keep a balance between very
long-term goals and you keep a balance
of very shortterm goals and go back and
forth between those two and oscillates
which is very hard mentally for people
to do uh you're less likely to end up
with a lot of urgent things right there
should be very few urgent things uh that
you need to do um and many things you
think is urgent isn't uh that important
right and you should be either
delegating them or ultimately
eliminating them but psychologically
we're wired to want to deal with just
the things that's urgent and if it's not
urgent now even important things will
struggle with the key is to then try to
uh create a forcing mechanism where you
actually schedule those types of things
too um so in in my particular case yes
there are a lot of things and everyone
thinks everything is uh really
urgent uh and this is where you have to
be very hard too as a leader I I think
the hardest single hardest thing
psychologically is we tend to want to be
liked U by our other people um but the
hardest things to do as a leader is you
have to have a very high bar for people
both in terms of what they need need to
do but uh the high bar means it's um
unless it's a hell yeah it's no right on
almost everything so I say no to so many
very very good ideas but if they're not
amazing I won't do it and every now and
then uh I find something that's amazing
um like the healthc care thing and I'm
like yeah uh I need to do this um but
there are only very very few things that
I can do myself um the rest of them I
have to find able competent people to do
nice uh final question how do you go
about balancing the demands of being a
CEO of a huge ass company with also
being a husband and a father and like
the personal side of things any tips
yeah um look uh you should ask my wife
about that one um no but I I think the
most important thing again um was
um I I I I don't um the the rally is
that you can't be amazing in everything
uh that's the first thing you have to um
understand and so I if if you're um one
one thing I do hate is when people talk
about work life balance um because
people talk about it as there being an
equilibrium of some sort um and the
reality is I think you're going to be
disappointed in life because my
experience and been nothing is ever
imbalance uh you're always going to be
um imbalanced in some shape or form so
if you think about it as entropy instead
you think about it as like um I don't um
work to live um I do what I love to do
so I have a lot of fun while doing it I
don't live to work but it's the um I I
really enjoy what I do too so it doesn't
feel like a huge drag and if you're in a
job where uh whatever you're doing feels
like a huge drag you should really TR
try I I can sympathize if you can't at
this moment but you should really try to
create a plan where you get out of um uh
out of that job and so that means in my
case work is very important uh relative
to that am I going to be the most
present father at the same time if that
means that it's time spent that is the
the primary indicator the reality is if
I think so and am I going to be the best
husband if that means that I time spent
is that or the best brother or the best
son by spending time I I I think I lose
because I'm not going to be able to
spend time because I do spend a
disproportionate amount of time on my
work and so I've gotten to grip with
that now what I do try to do is I try to
increase the quality of my interactions
even if I have limited
time and so a huge part of what I do
with my executive assistance weirdly
enough is I plan work less and I plan
all the private parts more so I try to
increase the quality of that um so as an
example one advice I ended up um getting
um by by someone um I think it was maybe
two years ago or something uh which was
a wonderful thing was that um this was a
father of
um um a u number of different kids and
he he was struggling with this thing
about how do I provide attention to each
child and then he realized that the
single best thing he could do was to I'm
calling to the Shas because it's a
longer story but he he um he realized
that the best thing he could do was to
spend one weekend individually with each
child um and I think it ended up being
five kids or something so basically 10%
of his weekends um is that a good
investment spending 10% of your weekends
individually with each child and um he
thought it would be and um the the way
he did do that is you have one year the
planet and so you figure out together
what do we both enjoy doing and so with
one of the children it was fishing so
they went away fishing for a week and
with another one they like roller
coasters so they went to theme park and
and went like crazy a third person um
may have been something else and so I
like that philosophy so much that I
actually copied it to elsewhere in life
too I have my friend groups and I try to
with my friends I don't get to see them
as often as I would like to but I try to
make something memorable uh with them in
my case I like football a lot so I tend
to go uh watch games with my friends we
try to find memorable games where we can
uh do something fun like an El classo or
I used to travel around to uh the old
firm and like pretty much all of the
Darby rivalry around uh the world with
one friend group uh another friend group
um we like driving experiences we go to
different places and do driving um so
it's it's been about sort of finding out
uh those different things um and I try
to do the same with my daughters one one
of them is more Arty the other one is
more activity driven it likes to be
outdoors and do um lots of different
things so just finding that um thing
that ticks with them spending that
quality time being present in that
moment not no ruptions no nothing um I I
know a lot of parents and again um um
there there's nothing wrong with that
either but but I I see it and there's
this tendency you're kind of like yeah
yeah let's play and then a word call
comes in and you're trying to do text
and you're you're not fully present
either so I I try to make sure at least
even if I can't spend as much time um to
increase the quality of each uh
interaction amazing Daniel thank you so
much this has been wonderful um I know
you don't like giving advice but if you
had to give one piece of advice for
anyone who's gone to the end of this and
who been inspired by your story and by
what you've built at Spotify what would
that be oh wow yeah I I don't like like
giving advice as you said
um well um I I I guess um my biggest
advice is um stay curious um and uh be
focused on learning um the biggest
single biggest investment you could do
is in
yourself and um it's how you spend your
time and you should spend it um this uh
appropriate amount of time in just
learning things it is fun to do so
you're going to have more social great
social interactions with VAR people you
may have not not found commonality and
if you know something about them that
you can relate to uh and I believe
you're just going to have a richer life
overall so I think that's a maybe cliche
but I think is still so true and so few
people do it so that would be my advice
brilliant Daniel thank you so much thank
you all right so that's it for this
week's episode of Deep dive thank you so
much for watching or listening all the
links and resources that we mentioned in
the podcast are going to be linked down
in the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye-bye